205 años del abrazo de maipú este
significó la independencia de chile y
este miércoles el presidente de
Argentina Alberto Fernández y su
homólogo chileno Gabriel borics lo
conmemoraron el tema principal de la
reunión fue la seguridad y sin lugar a
dudas como lo he mencionado en las
diferentes Cumbres internacionales hoy
día las bandas organizadas Las Bandas de
crimen organizado no respetan fronteras
y por lo tanto es tremendamente
relevante que ante las bandas
organizadas los estados organizados las
combatan las enfrenten y las alcancelen
Fernández aprovechó para hacer una
aclaración sobre una crítica que había
hecho la justicia chilena a veces veo
con dolor que algunas expresiones que
tengo
con mi pensamiento son interpretadas
aquí en Chile como actos de hostilidad a
Chile la verdad lo único que siento por
chile es un enorme amor ambos países
vecinos han mostrado afinidad desde la
llegada al poder de los dos presidentes
un contexto que se extiende por América
Latina que vive una ola de gobiernos
progresistas Argentina oficializó el
miércoles su regreso la unión de
Naciones suramericanas conocida como
unasur lo que tenemos que garantizar que
sirva al desarrollo económico de
nuestros pueblos unasur fue creada en
2008 por el fallecido presidente de
Venezuela Hugo Chávez y el presidente de
Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva 10
años después Argentina Brasil Chile
Colombia Paraguay y Perú con gobiernos
conservadores la abandonaron por
diferencias ideológicas